just rotating to the open area and there  will probably be more apology this is  what the Lakers do I'm wondering if the  bunch can't fall into this crazy  I chose all gets it back the Lopez the  cavalry principle inside the vincible  this is home game number six and broken  of course war number six in his seventh  season tunes  [Applause]  [Music]  I'm so Paul a rebound this Mendelson  struggling missed five of his first six  after 61 over 200 pounds and over six  rebounds a game at the guard position  [Music]  set defensively any confidence but the  one positive for the puck Gianna says  that really got naw  Wow get back three-time coach Otto all  right to Marcus back over you he needs  three rebounds here together go air ball  to dig good look for